[Applaudissements]
mais vous mais non gagne 1500 milles
c'est le jeu ma pauvre lucette
tu nous emmenaient avec les tories
[Applaudissements]
en manque de sexe au temps du district
est la bonne le chiffre qui fait rêver
tu vraiment pas cool de mouchin c'est
isabelle il dit juste excusez moi ma
chérie il dit juste que c'est faux parce
qu'il dise on peut gagner un million et
demi dont on sait maintenant c'est même
pas le est ce que vous partagez même on
me pire au meilleur des cas c'est énorme
avait gagné sept cent cinquante mille
euros donc c'est faux ben c'est déjà pas
mal
[Applaudissements]
elle avait calmé boom chéri d'amour on
se fait tout un
oui alors